I just hope that all of you guys can be
safe and cozy and you know whether
you're doing a solo thing whether you
have family or independent if you will
I've spent so many years as an
independent on Thanksgiving been like a
big solo flyer most of my life you know
didn't have a traditional family growing
up so I did like friends givings and now
I have this beautiful blended family if
they're blood wonderful if they're
friends and found that's just as good if
you like being just on your own and it's
a nice excuse to just shut down and take
care of yourself maybe that's what the
holidays were designed for to give
everybody a break or if you've got to
dive into that family drama and drink
some wine and get R and just best of
luck to you push comes to shove just do
a shot of gravy exactly and pray for
Monday thank you everybody